Guten Abend! Mein Name ist Ustola. Ich bin Erstein Aufwärtsstation. Ich bin hier in der Saufnahmegerichtung.
Ist das okay für Sie?
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Ich werde erst ihre persönlichen Daten aufnehmen. Dann komme ich gleich zu Ihnen aktuellen Bescheid.
Ja.
So, wie heißt es Ihnen?
Ich heiße Kevin Jäger.
Kevin Jäger. Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Folgenachnamen düştabieren?
Ja. Der Vorname ist Kevin K.E.V.I.N.
Ja.
Und der Familienname ist Jäger. J.A. Umlaut. G.E.R.
E.R. Kevin Jäger. Ja.
Bin ein Mann, ne?
Herr Jäger. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 19 Jahre.
19.
Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 12.09.2003.
2000.
Gut, ja. Wissen Sie, wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ja, ich wiege so 67 kg.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,8 m.
1,80 m.
Ja, Herr Jäger. Wie kann ich Ihnen heißen?
Was für Bescheid haben Sie momentan?
Ja, also ich habe seit Wochen eigentlich, dass ich mich schlecht fühle.
Dass ich so Halsschmerzen habe.
Und dass ich mich total schlapp fühle, dass ich Kopfschmerzen habe.
Manchmal auch Bauchschmerzen.
Und jetzt habe ich auch Fieber.
Das habe ich vorher gar nicht so bemerkt.
Und bitte?
Ja, Fieber haben Sie Fieber seit einer Woche oder?
Ja, wahrscheinlich schon länger. Ich habe das gar nicht gemessen.
Aber als es mir gar nicht besser ging, habe ich mal gemessen.
Und das ist, glaube ich, schon seit langer Zeit,
dass ich fast 39 Jahre alt bin.
39, okay.
Es ist mir auch nicht wundern, dass man sich dann schlappt fühlt.
Seit wann haben Sie Fieber?
Ungefähr?
Ich denke, bestimmt schon zwei Wochen.
Zwei Wochen.
Okay.
Deswegen waren Sie bei Ihrem Hausarzt?
Nein, ich habe hier immer gedacht, das geht von alleine wieder weg.
Aber jetzt habe ich langsam einfach auch ein bisschen Angst.
Mein Vater ist sehr jung an Krebs gestorben.
Und jetzt habe ich manchmal so ein Gedanke,
dass Sie am Gottes willen.
Was ist denn das? Warum geht es mir so schlecht?
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ja, Sie haben Hassschmerzen und Kopfschmerzen seit einer Woche.
Lese, das ist schon länger.
Okay, seit zwei oder drei Wochen.
Ja, bestimmt schon so lange. Ja, das wird noch nicht besser.
Und diese Kopfschmerzen sind im ganzen Kopfbereich oder?
Würde ich sagen, ja.
Okay.
Wie ist das mit der Kopfschmerz?
Wobei, das ist leicht, aber es ist nicht leicht.
Das ist schwank, so ein bisschen.
Also die Kopfschmerzen sind vielleicht bei fünf, sechs, so etwas.
Aber was unangenehmes sind diese Schluckbeschwerden.
Ich habe immer das Gefühl, dass das ein Widerstand ist.
Okay.
Und das ist auch irgendwie sehr schmerzhaft im Heiz.
Haben Sie einige Schwerdung in Ihrem Passbereich gemacht?
Ja, noblich habe ich das mal gedacht, dass das ein bisschen dicker ist.
Dicker?
Seit wann ist das so?
Vorher ist mir das nicht aufgefallen, aber jetzt seit ich diese Halsschmerzen habe,
ich habe so gut zwei Wochen, würde ich sagen.
Nein, zwei Wochen, okay.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Ich habe versucht, irgendwas zu lutschen, um die Halsschmerzen besser zu kriegen.
Husten wir auch so Halsbomber, um es gelutscht.
Ich habe auch mal Aspirin genommen gegen die Kopfschmerzen,
aber irgendwie hat das nicht viel gebracht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Hüsten?
Husten habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Nein, Husten habe ich nicht.
Oder haben Sie Atembeschwerden?
Luftnoten.
Atembeschwerden eigentlich nicht, ich habe nur das Schluckenzug so schrecklich.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schütterlfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Ich glaube, Nacht schwitzt sich schon, aber Schütterlfrost hatte ich jetzt nicht.
Aber Sie haben Nachschweiß.
Also ich schwitze schon in der Nacht, ja.
Okay.
Ja.
Haben Sie Schwellung an der Ankerpele bemerkt?
Aufgefallen ist mir da nichts. Nein.
Also ich glaube nicht.
Haben Sie Haartferenderung oder Haartauschlapp in Ihrem Körper bemerkt?
Nein, sie juckt auch nicht irgendwie oder so.
Nein, ich habe nichts gemacht.
Ein Blutung oder?
Einig schnell bekommen Sie eine schnelle Blödsäure zum Beispiel.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay. Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Also zurzeit ist der wirklich nicht besonders gut, weil ich eben beim Schlucken auch solche Schmerzen habe.
Am liebsten würde ich nur heiße Sachen trinken oder dann irgendwie so etwas, was runterrutscht.
Okay.
Seit zwei oder drei Wochen haben Sie keine Appetit.
Ja, das haut alles so hin.
Okay.
Haben Sie deswegen ein Gewichtverloren oder haben Sie eine Gewichtverländerung bemerkt?
Ne, also ich wicke ja nie so besonders viel, aber ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, dass ich noch mehr abgenommen habe.
Ne.
Keine Gewichtverländerung.
Okay.
Wenn Sie auf dieser Schwellung oder an dieser Schwellung dürreke, wie ist die Konsistenz?
Könnten Sie etwas davon mehr sagen oder ist es schmerzhaft?
Also ein bisschen weh tut das schon, wenn ich drücke ja und also wenn ich das hier zu fühle, denn muss ich sagen, es ist schon deutlich spürbar, dass da so ein Knubbel ist.
Ist es fest oder gummerartig?
Fest, fest hart ist das nicht, aber...
Gummi.
Ja, wie gummio, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Ja, wie ist Ihre Schlaf?
Ja, so ganz gut schlafe ich eigentlich nicht, aber auch vorher schon nicht.
Warum wissen Sie, warum Sie haben Schlafstörungen?
Ich glaube, vielleicht bin ich ein bisschen unruhig oder zappelig oder so oder gehe abends zu spät ins Bett, aber ich schlafe jedenfalls nicht so sehr gut.
Ja, haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen eigentlich nicht, das Einzige, was ich habe, ich habe ziemlich häufig Blähungen.
Blähungen.
Wie lange haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Auch eigentlich schon lange, eigentlich ja, vielleicht schon seit 3-4 Jahren oder so.
Vielleicht ist es auch nicht so gesund, kann auch sein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Herzprobleme?
Ich meine Herzklopfen, oder Herzrasen?
Sie sind etwas habisch.
Nichts, aber...
Haben Sie weitere Schmerzen?
Ich meine, Boruskop schmerzen, Bauchschmerzen, oder Muskelschmerzen, gelen Schmerzen?
Bauchschmerzen, ja genau, Bauchschmerzen habe ich.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, seit es mir so schlecht geht, habe ich diese komischen Bauchschmerzen, ja.
Seit 3 oder 2?
Seit gut 2 Wochen, ja.
Das wird aber irgendwie alles, habe ich den Eindruck, mehr schlechter und gar nicht besser.
Okay. Sind Sie stark oder wie bewahrtet?
Ja, das ist schon unangenehm.
Vielleicht so ein bisschen mehr als die Kopfschmerzen sogar.
Okay. Und sind diese Schmerzen dumpf oder stechend oder im ganzen Bauch?
Nee, eigentlich mehr so im oberen Bauchbereich und auch mehr auf der linken Seite.
Linken Seite.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ja, Sie haben Schmuckbeschwerde.
Ist das eher beim feste Nahrungsaufnahme oder Flüssigkeit auftreten?
Also, das Schlucken ist generell unangenehm, aber wenn ich natürlich jetzt nicht gut gekaut habe,
wenn irgendwas so trocken ist, dann kriege ich das überhaupt nicht runter.
Also, Flüssigkeit geht ja schon eher, aber Beton tut es eigentlich bei jedem Schluck.
Im heißen Bauchbereich, aber nicht hinter dem Brustbein.
Nein.
Nein. Okay.
Ja, Herr Gabger, ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindelig ist mir nicht, nein.
Nein. Okay. Haben Sie Konzentration, Probleme?
Ja, jetzt, wo es mir so schlecht geht, würde ich sagen, habe ich so ein bisschen Konzentrationsprobleme.
Also, ich könnte jetzt nicht arbeiten.
Ich bin jetzt schon seit einer Woche nicht mehr bei der Arbeit gewesen, weil ich gemerkt habe, das geht nicht mehr.
Okay.
Aber mein Chef hat Verständnis dafür.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin in der Ausbildung zum technischen Zeichner.
Technischen Zeichner.
Okay.
Und ja, leiden Sie an Irgendwas für Erkrankungen, Herr Gabger.
Ich meine, Schilderösen-Funktion-Probleme.
Ja, also ich habe eigentlich nur zwei Sachen, dass ich seit mehreren Wochen schon eine Entzündung habe der Achilles-Szene.
Und dann habe ich noch eigentlich ja chronisch, kann man sagen, so eine Unverträglichkeit von Sonnenlicht.
Insbesondere im Gesicht und an den Händen halt die Sachen, die der Sonder so ausgesetzt sind.
Und wenn ich da also nicht gut einen Sonnenschutz auftrage oder so, dann muss ich in zwei, vier zwei dann ein bisschen mit Cortison-Salbe dagegen angeben.
Sie hatten Achilles-Szene-Probleme.
Ja.
Wann war das?
Das habe ich immer noch. Das habe ich jetzt schon seit dem Wochenende, dass ich nicht gut laufen kann.
Okay.
Ja, nehmen Sie Regal-Missing Medikamenten?
Nein, nur weil wir da eben diese Salbe da und mal eben etwas gegen Kopfschmerzen oder so. Aber regelmäßig nehme ich sonst nichts.
Nehmen Sie Parastomol oder?
Parastomol oder Aspirin je nachdem.
Okay.
Burdunzi, bist du operiert?
Ne, ich habe noch nie eine Operation.
Ganz operiert.
Ja, herrja, ja.
Aufgrund, ja, im Besuch auf ihre Aktuellen beschwerden. Haben Sie dafür eine bestimmte Auslöserbemeld?
Zum Beispiel, vor drei oder zwei Wochen, hatten Sie eine Erkältung?
Ja, man ist ja jetzt immer mal so ein bisschen erkältet, wo es Herbst wird.
Aber das ist ja keine richtige Erkältung. Ne, eine Erkältung ist ja nach ein paar Tagen weg.
Ich habe auch erst gedacht, es geht nach ein paar Tagen weg. Aber es wird ja immer schlechter.
Burdunzi, in letzter Zeit häufig krank als sonst? Ich meinte, infektiöse Krankheit.
Nein, das kann ich eigentlich nicht sagen. Nein, also jetzt im letzten halben Jahr, im Sommer war ich immer ganz gesund.
Ganz gut, ja. Jetzt würde ich über Ihre Lebensgewohnheit etwas fragen. Brauchen Sie, Herr Yoga?
Hin und wieder, ja, in Gesellschaft brauche ich mal eine Zigarette mit, aber ich habe keine zu Hause.
Wie viele Zigarretten täglich ungefähr?
Wenn ich in der Woche fünf rauche, ist es viel.
Fünf Zigarretten?
In der Woche.
Seit wann?
Also wirklich nur, weiß ich, aus Gesellschaft, wenn man irgendwo mit anderen zusammen ist.
Und Herr Yoga, seit wann rauchen Sie so?
Ach ja, wenn man so anfängt mit 16 findet man das spannend. Aber so richtig geschmeckt hat mir das nie.
Seit sechsten. Okay, und trinken Sie Alkohol, gelegantisch oder legalmäßig?
Ja, nicht so oft. Wenn man zu arbeiten muss, kann man sich das ja nicht erlauben.
Aber am Wochenende trinke ich schon gerne mal einen Schluck, ja.
Was trinken Sie? Bier oder?
Bier oder auch mal Long Drinks mit ein bisschen Schuss drin.
Okay, und bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Rhein-Ruth-Tüne-Frage.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit den Drogen?
Drogen? Nein, da konnte ich mich nie zu durchrücken.
Ja, ganz gut. Okay. Herr Yoga, sind Sie verheiratet oder?
Nein, nein, nein, ich bin...
Ja, Sie sind ja jung.
Aber ich wohne mit meiner Freundin zusammen.
Freundin, Sie waren okay. Seit wann haben Sie Freunde?
Ja, wir wohnen schon eine ganze Weile zusammen, seit ich in der Ausbildung bin, also ein Jahr.
Und Sie sind übrigens auch so komisch krank, der geht genauso schlecht wie mir.
Genauso. Sie hat auch ähnliche Beschwerden momentan.
Sie hat auch ganz ähnliche Beschwerden, ja.
Okay. Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder im Privatleben?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Keine Stress? Okay.
Jetzt habe ich Stress, weil ich mich krank fühle und nicht zur Arbeit gehen kann.
Und weil ich natürlich auch so ein bisschen Sorgen habe in meinem Alter, wo soll das hinführen, wenn ich so krank bin, das geht ja nicht.
Ja, ich verstehe ja.
Und ja, Herr Jagger, machen Sie realmäßig Sport?
Ja, wenn ich dazu komme, mache ich schon Sport.
Ich spiele mal Fußball mit meinen Freunden und fahre ich regelmäßig mit dem Fahrrad.
Alles gut, okay.
Ja, sind Sie vorstandig geimpft gegen Corona und auch gegen Corona?
Ja, gegen Corona bin ich auch alle fälle geimpft und was man sonst so alles haben kann.
Ich denke mal, da haben meine Eltern schon gesagt, ja.
Okay, ganz gut, ja.
Und waren Sie in Leicester seit im Ausland?
Im Ausland? Nein, da bin ich nicht geblieben.
Dann in den nächsten sechs Monaten zum Beispiel?
Nein, da war ich nicht im Ausland.
Okay.
Und ja, ich würde gerne auch etwas über Ihre Familiengeschichte wissen.
Ihre Vater, Mutter leiden an Irgendwelchen vor Erkrankungen.
Ich sagte ja, mein Vater ist ganz früh gestorben.
Ja, sie hat es.
Er hatte Schildrösenkrebs.
Und ja, das ist natürlich so etwas, was mir jetzt auch so ein bisschen Sorgen macht,
dass sie denkt, Gott, es fehlt hoffentlich habe ich nicht auch irgendwie eine schlimme Erkrankung.
Ja, ja, ich verstehe die Sorge, ja.
Und meine Mutter, die hat jetzt, wo sie ein bisschen älter ist,
hat sie es ein bisschen übergewichtig, die hat ein Diabetes.
Diabetes.
Typ zwei Diabetes, ne?
Typ zwei.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Geschwister habe ich nicht mehr.
Keine.
Okay.
Herr Jagger, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen in den Gestalt.
Möchten Sie etwas ins Vorgehen oder etwas fragen?
Ja, ich möchte jetzt natürlich einfach wissen,
ob das was Schlimmes sein kann.
Und vor allem auch, was man dagegen machen kann, dass das endlich mal aufwört.
Ja, Herr Jagger.
Bisher habe ich eine Nese durchgeführt.
Und ja, ich vermute, dass sie an eine infektiöse Krankheit leiden.
Ach, du liebe Güte, muss ich dann im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Nein, sie muss nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Aber wir bleiben sehr weit.
Ich habe es nicht mehr aufwärts.
Aber natürlich muss ich auch aufwärts.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Hab ich ein Kollege, der fragt,
natürlich kann ich das sagen.
Ich denke, es ist gut, ausführlich, an im Nest.
Ich glaube auch, ja.
Sie hat auch sehr schön selber moderiert, dass sie so gedacht hat,
ich muss jetzt das und das fragen.
Das möchte ich noch fast zu Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten wissen.
Sehr schön gemacht.
Das Einzige bei den Befunden, sind Sie auf diese,
haben Sie Schiene gekommen?
Haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie Schiene?
Ja, da vielleicht noch mal so eine Variation einbauen.
Aber Sie haben tatsächlich so viel gefragt.
Alles klar.
Gut.
Aber ich denke mal, das war sehr schön, auch wirklich komplett gefragt.
Sehr schön an im Nest geführt.
Aber einige Fragen.
Sie haben noch Fragen.
Ja, welche Fragen haben Sie denn noch?
Zum Beispiel Glieder Schmerzen.
Ich habe gefragt.
Gefragt?
Ja.
Mundgehäusch.
Ja, Feuerwerk Mundgehäusch.
Und ich habe Bauch Schmerzen,
Muslimea, einige Detaliere,
weil es eine Menge, eine Menge
denken, die ja Muslimea denken.
Und ein bisschen Detaliere.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Können Sie auch fangen, als das geschieht?
Komisch also.
Okay.
Ich habe keine Schallung.
Ja.
Guten Abend Frau Oberarstein.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe sie denn gesehen.
Okay.
Es handelt sich um Kevin Jagger.
Ich habe heute einen sehr grossen Patient.
Er hat eine sehr große
Schweche, Sunimende, Kölkale, Schweche, Su uns.
Er berichtet, dass er seit zwei Wochen FIBA, HB, er hat,
er hat das FIBA nicht gelassen, aber für ihn
vermutlich ist es über neun, dreißig Grad gewesen.
Die FIBA ist dumpf und diffüsant und auf einer Schmerzgala legen sie bei fünf und sechs.
Zwischen fünf und sechs?
Ja, und dann Patienten ist,
ja, heiße Schwerung, nämlich Laff-Odenopathy im Heißbereich aufgefangen.
Eine Luft-Odenopathy im Heiß, ja, okay?
Seit zwei Wochen und er hat auch Schluck beschwerden.
Er klackte weiter über Nachschweiß und in Appeten, seit zwei oder drei Wochen
eine Linkseite geobarbe schmärtsen, dumpfe Oberbau schmärtsen,
in geferen seit drei Wochen und ja, seit drei Wochen.
Die Laff-Knoten, die geschworenen Laff-Knoten sind gummartig,
sind gummartig und schmärtshaft.
Die vegetative Anäme ist unanfällig,
die ähärmlichen Laff-Knoten sind unanfällig.
Die ähärmlichen Laff-Knoten sind unanfällig,
und den Gezicht bereicht,
der gegen Neime,
nimmt er Korpsol-Zerbe, Bay Bedarf,
und er nimmt Pausetomol
und Aspirin, Bay Bedarf,
Bay Bedarf ein.
Er raut ungefähr
seit acht Jahren,
fünf Zigaretten pro Woche.
Nein, das nicht seit 18 Jahren,
der Junge ist 19 Jahre alt.
Ah, das ist seit, sorry, seit sechs Jahren
Entschuldigung.
Er hat seit drei Jahren,
seit mit 16 hatte er gesagt,
hat er angefangen.
Ha, mit sechs.
Okay.
Und er trinke
sehr selten Alkohol anbohnen.
Ja, wichtig zu erwähnen ist, dass er eine Freundin hat, die auch an den ähnlichen Beschwerden leidet.
Er ist ausgebildet zum technischen Zeichner.
Er ist ein regionaler Sport- und Fußballspieler.
Er ist in Betracht.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt mit den Patienten diagnostisch?
Diagnostisch werde ich erst in Körperisch untersuchen.
Er ist inspektiv im Rachenbereich.
Er ist auch aus Kultation des Herzen und der Lungen.
Er ist auch eine Parapation des Abdomens.
Er ist eine Hepatio-Syprenomegeli-Sübestimmung.
Er ist ein differenzialer Blutbild.
Er ist ein Blutfenk- und Gechemindikat-CRP-Rachnagentest.
Er ist für Influenza und Bakterien, Ergärme und Antikörpöse.
Er ist ein öfterer und optimaler Berasch.
Was erwarten Sie da?
Er ist ein sehr komischer Berater.
Was wäre die Therapie des Patienten?
Er ist eine Symptomatische Therapie.
Er ist ausreichend und kritisch.
Wie muss der Patient sich verhalten?
Was soll er jetzt machen?
Er ist ausreichend und kritisch.
Was waren die Punkte?